the joe rogan experience
yeah was the last time you had a job um
2007. what'd you do i worked at sears i
did loss prevention
it was amazing it was one of the best
day jobs ever really well my cousin was
the boss which helped
and he let me work from 10 to six which
is great comedy hours
and then we were like plain clothed i
guess just
uh oh so you just walked around busted
people stealing yeah it had like a
little
radio on the uh the belt and then we had
a crazy camera system
for 2007. like it was at like i think we
had 82 cameras
and you could zoom and [ __ ] and you just
watch people all day and then you'd walk
around the store and be like
we got to keep an eye on the camera 11.
so you're like a secret engine
it was fun it was really fun and we got
to stop shoplifters and [ __ ]
it was amazing i missed i actually miss
it it was really fun
wow i used to work for a private
investigator
and uh similar yeah it was it actually
turned out
it was one of those people where you
meet and you go this guy should be a
comedian
he was hilarious his name is dave dolan
he's dead now and uh i keep a voicemail
message from him
just because he was such he was such a
character
he was just such a [ __ ] character and
he was hilarious and he got a dui
and uh they took away his license and
what he really needed was not an
assistant he needed a driver
so i just had a good have a good
driver's license so uh
but i was working as an assistant and
then we became friends and we'd bus
people
mostly people that were stealing uh
insurance money
they were like doing things like
pretending they were injured and they
take another job on the side and then
we'd catch them we'd have to get there
like five o'clock in the morning and
wait for them to get up and go to work
and then follow them take pictures of
them and [ __ ] that's fun
it was a fun gig yeah it was fun it was
real fun too because he was actually
cousins with bill downes who was one of
the owners of the comedy connection
build no many downs that's it yeah
i worked for that guy me too many times
and uh
that was dave was his cousin so it was
like just dumb luck
i became friends with this guy but from
driving him around
and his cousin was the guy one of the
guys that owned the comedy connection
wow yeah i loved uh working at syria it
was fun i feel like comedians are
actually good at that jump because we're
hyper aware and we're doing a lot of
judging anyway so you want you like an
audience come in you're like that guy's
going to hate me this woman's too drunk
that guy's fat
right and i think it's similar to
shoplifting like something's up with
this guy
well it's also like it sounds like a job
that doesn't suck
like you can wander around no one's
telling you what to do it's not like
you're stuck at a [ __ ] desk
going over stupid numbers or something
you don't give a [ __ ] about
yeah and it's low maintenance physically
i know guys in new york that are like
movers for their day job and i'm like
you can't have a [ __ ] manual labor
job
like you get up at times and you're
carrying couches like you're not going
to hit an open mic at 8 00 pm you're
gonna be exhausted
yeah but i loved it and having your
cousin as the boss is great i streamed
through a sears at
my last day you took your clothes off i
yeah we decided well
i didn't want to i couldn't go naked
because it's like a sex crime so i
covered my face with a brown paper bag
and bought like a candy thong necklace
at um i can't it's not a necklace it's a
candy thong at spencer's gifts and i
wore that
i got videos of my friend my buddy just
sent it to me i hadn't seen it in like
12 years
it's a sex crime if you take your
clothes off yeah if you run through
naked yeah hilarious that's a sex crime
so i was like i better have no clothes
on which is how you are naturally how
you're born
you are a walking sex crime i get you
can't have people
running around naked wait a minute wait
a minute but
why not what is the problem well
okay if a woman walked through a store
naked do you think she should go to jail
i don't think she i should think i would
assume she has mental problems i think
she should she
just likes to be naked if if a gal goes
through a place
like uh maybe you're a target and some
some gal just decides to take off her
clothes
and walk as far as she can to target
before they arrest her
are you in support of her being arrested
and taken to a jail and
hit with a sex crime no i'm not in
support of that but i
there's a lot of things that rules and
laws that i'm not in support of that but
it seems like it's okay if a guy gets
arrested doing that
well it depends on what he's doing i
suppose that's how i feel
if a guy's running around naked if he's
just running and jogging
like flopping around inside target yeah
that guy's a criminal
i don't need to see him is he hard or
not it's a good question that's very
good
interesting he's a hard criminal yeah if
he's hard he goes straight to jail
well that's like a right to the electric
chair that's a particular
sexual but just as [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
electric condom what if he's got
all his clothes on except for his [ __ ]
and balls and he's just
he's just riding out you know he's got a
just coming out of the uh they're not a
rule in san francisco like you can walk
around naked you just can't have a heart
on
is that true really that's why i just
heard uh brian callan
say that watch google that google that
we need to find out this
is true in new york i know in the park
you can be naked i think naked
you can walk around topless i've seen a
couple women women are allowed to go
tapas because men
used to be able to go top well men could
go topless forever but there was a rule
that said the women couldn't and women
are like well this is [ __ ] and
they're right and i think a lot of them
didn't even want to be topless
right but they were like well this is
[ __ ] up people telling us that our nip
like sarah silverman sarah silverman
just posted on instagram
a photo of her mirror like her bathroom
mirror and you can see her tits in the
mirror
she did it on purpose to like make a
point like why first of all she did it
because she has great tits
okay she wanted everybody to see her
great tits they're pretty fantastic i
missed it i'm bummed but also like
why is it okay if you could see my tits
why is it okay to see my nipples but you
can't see her nipples
like what do we babies i agree that's
either free the nipple i'm for it
instagram is really hardcore on that but
twitter
you could do porn yeah they'll have porn
on [ __ ] twitter there's poor
knowledge i follow porn stars they
watch them [ __ ] maybe i'll do some porn
you think so yeah why not
i got a dick you do have a dick yeah
that's what i hear
yeah it's nice do you think that uh you
should be
arrested if you just walk around naked
um
if i was making the rule i i don't know
it's hard because it's uh
it's all in what you do with it if
you're rubbing it on people yeah yeah
certainly
just walk around yeah and kids kids
point at you and laugh and you go huh
that's the thing it depends i mean there
should be adult areas where you can walk
around
naked i think uh like a nude beach yes
they have those they have those
yeah but arrested i don't know i would
just assume someone is a little
off mentally walking around naked
because there are um societary
uh norms i don't think so
it sounds like a guy sounds like a horse
that wins the
kentucky derby it says that they changed
the public nudity law
in san francisco in like 2013
i think but we were there when you shot
your special in 100
i was at the top of lombard street and
there was a large gathering of naked
people
so i don't know what the [ __ ] that was
about nonsense
so there was they didn't get it stop
there's cops right there they didn't
stop them from doing anything have
pictures of it
so i don't know what that was about what
am i gonna do
[Applause]